foreign  I used to ask myself a lot of questions  Scott you're at ex-con  how are you an Avenger that doesn't make  sense  but everywhere I go people tell me the  same thing thank you Spiderman  people still need help Dad that's why we  made this  [Music]  like a satellite for deep space but  Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending  a signal down to the quantum Realm  turn it off  now  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  where  are we  [Music]  the secret Universe beneath ours  what are you so afraid of  there's something I never told you do  this place  it isn't what you think  [Music]  I'm gonna get you home  and give you more time  if you help me  [Music]  so  What's it gonna be  Ant-Man  [Music]